[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم الكنيست الاسرائيلي يقر
مشروع قانون اثار جدلا كبيرا اقترحته
حكومه نتنياهو لتقييد بعض صلاحيات المحكمه
العليا المعارضه تحذر من اتجاه اسرائيل
نحو كارثه ومع استمرار الاعتراضات في
الشارع وداخل الجيش رئيس الاركان يطلع
نتنياهو على خطوره الموقف عسكريا وامنيا
واتحاد العمال يلوح بالاضره روسيا تقول ان
هجوما بالمسيرات استهدف مبنيين في العاصمه
موسكو والسلطات المواليه لها تكشف عن هجوم
بمسيرات على مستودع ذخيره بالقرد تقول ان
هجوما روسيا بالمسيرات استهدف مستودعا
للحبوب قرب اوديسا وتؤكد اسقاط ثلاث منها
ايلون ماسك يزيل شعار طائر الازرق لموقعي
تويتر ويضع محله حرف اكس وي سيعرف الان
باسم موقع x ويمكن للمستخدمين البحث عن
اكس دوت كوم للوصول الى الصفحه الرئيسيه
للموقع ويشير الشعار الجديد الى شركه التي
اعلن ماسك تاسيسها لتكون المالكه الرسميه
للمنصه نادي باريس سان جيرمان الفرنسي
يسمح لنادي الهلال السعودي بالتحدث مع
مهاجمه الدولي كيليان باتي بعد اقتراح
نادي الهلال 300 مليون يورو على بطل فرنسا
لضم هداف مونديال 2022 الى صفوفه وذلك
نقلا عن وكاله فرانسبريس من مصدر قريب من
المفاوضات
الى اللقاء